>>> Don't look now, but there's
something funny going on over
there at the bank, George.
>> I've never really seen one.
That's got all the earmarks of
being a run.
>> The classic scene from it's
a wonderful life, dramatizes
the panic involved in a run on
the bank.
It happens when there's a loss
of confidence in the bank, and
that leads to large
withdrawals.
The bank can't pay everyone who
wants their money all at once,
and it fails.
During the great depression,
thousands of banks failed.
9,000 to be exact.
Taking $7 billion worth of
customers assets with them.
That's why the new deal
included laws to ensure
deposits and boost confidence
in financial institutions.
The federal deposit insurance
corporation, the fdic, was
created in 1933.
And today covers up to $250,000
per depositor at fdic-insured
banks.
Actual bank failures still
happen.
There were a lot during the
great financial crisis in 2008.
But in recent years, just a
handful every year.
And none in 2021 and 2022.
The danger with a bank run is
that panic can spread to other
banks.
It's called contagion.
>> Day one, there were two
people.
And then four.
And then 16.
In 3 months, it's a billion.
That's where we're headed.
>> So what starts as a problem
at a single bank can quickly
turn into a crisis for the
entire system.
That's what happened during the
great financial crisis in 2008,
and it's why the collapse of
silicon valley bank, the second
largest U.S. Bank failure of
all time, has Wall Street on
edge.
>> A look at how this all
actually works.
When you have a run on a bank,
how do you prevent future bank
failures?
Is the government doing too
much, too little?
We also invited the white house
to join us tonight on the
program to help answer American
questions.
They declined that invitation,
but let's bring in Larry
Summers for his insight.
Secretary Summers, thank you
very much for being with us
tonight.
And I just want to begin with
your level of concern.
I mean, we have more banks
tonight on the brink.
What do the American people
need to be preparing for?
>> I don't think this is a time
for panic or alarm.
This is not 2008 where people
needed to be worried about
whether they could get their
money from the atm machine.
It absolutely is not that.
There may well be concerns at
certain banks, and they may
even be more bank closures.
But the government's made it
clear that it is determined to
ensure that all depositors will
be able to get their money
promptly and in full.
That's what it signaled with
its actions at svb, the silicon
valley bank.
And signature bank and with the
support that it provided to the
banking system more broadly.
It's not just people with
insured deposits under $250,000
who will be able to get their
money back.
It's people with money over
$250,000.
>> Right.
>> So there are real issues
here.
There's major failures of
financial regulation, but this
should not be something that
causes panic or consternation
or fear among your viewers.
>> You know, it is so
significant, though.
Roger Altman who worked in the
treasury, he called to us this
week breathtaking what the
government has done here,
stepping in, in this way.
Now the question becomes,
secretary, what does the fed
do?
What does the fed do next week
on interest rates?
Given their dual mandate is
maximum employment and price-
ability, but they know whatever
they do if they raise rates
will really impact bank
stability right now.
>> Look, I think the fed has no
choice but to remain focused on
the inflation issue.
If inflation goes up and
inflation is not controlled,
we're going to have higher
interest rates, and higher
interest rates are going to
make these problems more
serious.
The judgment the fed's going to
have to make is that because of
what's happened, there's surely
going to be some reductions in
the supply of credit, and so in
a sense without the fed raising
interest rates, monetary
conditions have tightened.
And the question the fed's
going to have to ask itself is
have monetary conditions
tightened sufficiently that
we're responding to the
inflation threat without any
further rate increases or
without a further rate increase
this month?
And I don't think we can know
the answer to that question
with confidence.
And every day we're getting new
information as we see what
happens to banks, as we see how
businesses are responding to
these developments.
Certainly the 50 basis points
that I and others thought was a
viable option before all of
this financial difficulty, that
has to be off the table.
But I would be concerned if the
fed were to stop all together
raising interest rates, that it
would be sending a signal that
it was quite alarmed about the
economy, and people would feel
that if the fed was alarmed,
they should be alarmed.
And it could be
counterproductive.
So I don't have a clear view
right now.
My instinct is if they can find
a way to safely raise rates by
25 basis points, that's
probably the better thing to be
looking for, but that's not a
judgment that one can
confidently make right now.
>> That's a great point.
I mean, they sort of have to
get it right like a goldilocks
decision here.
The former head of the fdic
said the fed should pause
completely on raising rates.
Summers is saying you're going
to the markets.
You have a question.
>> She's not the only one who
said they should pause all
together.
A week ago, inflation was still
issue number one for the
typical American family.
Tonight, issue number one for
the typical American family if
you look at Google search
trends is, is my money safe?
Should I move my money?
A lot has changed in the past
week.
Talk to us, secretary Summers,
about the inflation fight and
how that should still be in the
forefront of what the fed is
trying to do in your view.
>> Look, Americans' money is
safe.
Americans' money will be safe
if they don't raise rates at
all.
Americans' money will be safe
if they do raise rates by 25
basis points because the
government has indicated that
it's standing behind bank
deposits.
And as that message is repeated
and becomes clear, as people
see that those who have
deposited money even in the
banks that failed, and even the
people who were not insured are
getting their money back in
full.
But we are still also seeing
very substantial rates of
inflation.
And if those substantial rates
of inflation continue they will
erode people's purchasing power
and their ability to spend.
They will be incorporated in
yet higher interest rates,
which will mean further
financial strains.
So I think the fed has to
tiptoe very carefully through
what is certainly a mine field
at this point.
But again, inflation is a real
threat, not being able to get
your money out of the bank is a
fear, but it is not a realistic
possibility or realistic threat
that Americans are facing.
>> Phil?
>> One of the things I've been
trying to figure out through
the course of this week,
speaking personally, was
stunned by the scale and the
speed by which the government
reacted and coalesced.
Using 133 for the fed facility,
what else do they have in the
chamber to use a bad analogy.
When you're thinking about what
might happen next, if something
happens next, what else can
they do?
That should give people
confidence that there's more
left.
>> They have a huge, they have
done a huge thing.
It is a major source, if
somebody was prepared to loan
money against a $300,000 house,
they were prepared to loan
$400,000.
That would be a major source of
support.
And that's, in effect, what the
government has done by saying
it's going to lend against all
these bonds at par, not against
their current market value.
So what the government is going
to, the main thing the
government is going to do is
show that it is money good
behind its words, and I think
that will be reassuring on the
question of deposits.
Ultimately, one could imagine
extending an fdic guarantee in
a formal way to all deposits as
a matter of logic.
I would be very surprised if
that was necessary at this
point.
I don't think the real concerns
here are about deposits.
They'll get paid.
The real concerns here are that
the banking industry is under
considerable stress, that they
were too bold, that they're
going to be regulated more
heavily, and how we do that
without precipitating a credit
crunch that generates a
recession, that is the very
serious concern that we have
here.
And so I am much more concerned
about a continuing, strong flow